hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live es war das große Projekt der CSU in
der letzten Bundesregierung die PKW-Maut
und ist krachen gescheitert allerdings
gescheitert mit folgen die uns noch
heute beschäftigen es geht um
243 Millionen Euro Steuergeld die der
Bund für die geplatzte Pkw-Maut als
Schadensersatz an die geplanten
Betreiber bezahlen muss und bei uns geht
es deshalb heute um die Frage muss der
Bund das wirklich oder könnte auch der
damalige Verkehrsminister scheuer dafür
haften denn der amtierende
Verkehrsminister Wissing von der FDP
will nun durch ein Gutachten prüfen
lassen ob scheuer belangt werden könnte
deshalb heute die Frage bei uns droht
andreas Scheuer eine Klage wegen des
Maut Desasters das wollen wir heute für
euch klären ihr könnt mit diskutieren
Fragen stellen im Stream oder per Mail
denn wir können das mit zwei Experten
heute bei uns besprechen zuerst sprechen
wir mit Dominik chapter er ist unser
Korrespondent im Hauptstadtstudio und
jetzt bei uns hallo Dominik schön dass
du da bist hallo Alissa grüß Dich
Dominik heute war das auch Thema in der
Bundespressekonferenz du warst dabei du
hast zugehört gibt es denn schon mehr
Details über dieses Gutachten und was
daraus folgen könnte es gibt immerhin
die Details dass das jetzt geklärt
werden soll das Rechtssicherheit
hergestellt werden soll das
Verkehrsministerium Volker Wissing und
sein Sprecher haben verkündet dass sie
ganz gerne wissen möchten ob Sie
eventuell Herrn scheuer höchstpersönlich
dafür verantwortlich machen können also
ob es Regressforderungen geben könnte
das soll jetzt juristisch geklärt werden
durch ein Gutachten es ist nicht ganz
klar ob sich das nur gegen Herrn scheuer
oder auch andere Mitarbeiter im
Ministerium handelt oder richten soll
und das ist auch nicht ganz klar wie
lange es dauern soll aber es ist schon
gut möglich dass das jetzt einige Wochen
und Monate braucht dieses Gutachten also
das Ergebnis dieses Gutachtens werden
wir sehr wahrscheinlich nicht innerhalb
der nächsten Woche mitgeteilt bekommen
und deswegen kann man noch nicht genau
sagen wie das Ganze ausgehen wird die
juristischen Detail klären wir gleich
hier im Studium mit Christoph Schneider
wir bleiben jetzt aber mit dir erstmal
noch mal bei der politischen Dimension
dieses ganze hat hören auch mal zusammen
rein in einen Ton des Verkehrsministers
von Volker Wissing der hat sich nämlich
bei uns im ZDF auch geäußert denn es
geht ja nicht um etwas was man aus der
Portokasse bezahlen kann sondern um 243
Millionen Euro also knapp eine viertel
Milliarde Steuergelder für die die
Menschen arbeiten mussten und die haben
ein Recht darauf zu wissen wie geht das
jetzt weiter warum haftet niemand oder
haftet jemand
warum haftet niemand oder haftet jemand
sagt Volker Wissing aber die große Frage
auch jetzt gerade bei uns warum macht er
das denn jetzt zum Thema das ist ja
tatsächlich kein ganz neues Thema also
warum das Gutachten jetzt hat das auch
ein politisches Kalkül ja absolut es hat
ein großes politisches Kalkül man muss
auch davor sagen dass er Wissing uns
auch im ZDF schon vor einigen Wochen
gesagt hat dass er das ganze prüfen
möchte Neues jetzt eben dass er noch mal
gesagt hat in einem Interview dass er
das mit einem Gutachten machen möchte
das ist so gesehen gar nicht so neu der
Zeitpunkt ist schon verdächtig denn in
Bayern wird bald gewählt es gibt eine
Landtagswahl in diesem Herbst in Bayern
also da ist der Verdacht schon
naheliegend das ist natürlich auch darum
geht den Vorgänger irgendwie einen
mitzugeben und zu sagen ich bin da nicht
verantwortlich die CSU ist dafür
verantwortlich Klammer auf das stimmt ja
auch also wenn jemand verantwortlich ist
für diese Pkw-Maut dann ist es die CSU
und so kann man noch mal schön die
Fehler der CSU aus FDP sich noch mal
schön allen präsentieren in der Tat hat
ja andreas Scheuer diese Verträge
unterschrieben Ende 2018 also bevor der
EuGH der Europäische Gerichtshof dazu
beurteilt hat ein halbes Jahr später hat
er dann gesagt das war eben nicht Europa
rechtskonform diese Pkw-Maut und die CSU
hat quasi andreas Scheuer hat das quasi
gemacht wieder besseren Wissens denn es
gab Warnungen und genau diese Kritik
dieses Debakel das kann man jetzt im
CSU-Minister noch mal schön dem xcsu
wenn es dann noch mal schön aufs Brot
schmieren hat natürlich auch Wahlkampf
taktische Gründe und warum da jetzt
überhaupt so eine große Summe auch
zusammengekommen ist was gerade auch
schon ein paar Details von dieser
Geschichte angesprochen was da also los
war weil die Story ist ja jetzt
natürlich auch schon ein paar Jahre
älter wir haben jetzt mal ein paar
Hintergründe zusammengefasst Laura
Rosinus hat das gemacht wir schauen mal
zusammen rein
erst war sie das Prestigeprojekt der CSU
dann endete sie im Desaster scheuers
Pkw-Maut aber von vorne
2014 beschlossen Union und SPD eine
sogenannte infrastrukturabgabe für Pkw
auf Autobahnen und Bundesstraße
ausländische Fahrer sollten auf
Autobahnen deutsche über die Kfz-Steuer
entlastet werden aber die Umsetzung der
Maut lag mehrere Jahre auf Eis wegen
Bedenken der EU und eines Verfahrens der
EU-Kommission gegen Deutschland
Ende 2018 dann schlossverkehrsminister
scheuer Verträge mit Firmen die für den
Bund kontrollieren und kassieren sollen
noch bevor endgültig sicher war ob die
Maut vor europäischen Recht Bestand
haben wird sogar seine Vertragspartner
sollen scheuer angeboten haben auf das
Urteil des Europäischen Gerichtshofs zu
warten dann 2019 stoppte der Europäische
Gerichtshof tatsächlich die Maut sie sei
rechtswidrig und diskriminierend so die
Begründung kurz nach der
Urteilsverkündung veranlasst es scheuer
die bereits geschlossenen Verträge mit
den vorgesehenen mautbetreibern zu
kündigen die wiederum forderten
Schadensersatz in Höhe von 560 Millionen
Euro schon in der vergangenen
Wahlperiode befasse sich ein
Untersuchungsausschuss mit der
gescheiterten Maut und deren Folgen
243 Millionen Euro soll der Bund an die
eins vorgesehenen Betreiberfirmen zahlen
das hatte eine Verständigung nach einem
Schiedsverfahren ergeben ob der Bund auf
dem Schaden sitzen bleibt das soll nun
auch Gutachter prüfen
über mögliche rechtliche Konsequenzen
geht es jetzt gleich noch in der Sendung
aber an Dich erst noch die Frage wenn
scheuer schon damals so eine Kritik
stand warum wurden denn keine
politischen Konsequenzen gezogen das
kann ich auch nicht richtig beantworten
das fragen sich ja auch alle meine
Kollegin Christiane hübsche hat dazu
meinen ganz Tolles
inside-politics gemacht auf YouTube zu
finden schon vor drei Jahren haben wir
uns die Frage gestellt warum ist andreas
Scheuer eigentlich noch im Amt die kurze
Antwort war damals weil die CSU die
schützende Hand über ihn gehalten hat
also er hatte immer die Rückendeckung
seines Parteichefs es war immer klar
dass die CSU den Verkehrsminister
stellen möchte und punkten möchte eben
auch politisch punkten möchte mit der
PKW Maut obwohl alle schon wussten das
wird echt schwierig dass das ganze
Europa rechtskonform ist also die
berechtigte Frage ist warum ist andreas
Scheuer noch im Amt er ist auch immer
noch Abgeordneter im Deutschen Bundestag
es wäre eigentlich sagen viele nicht nur
aus der Opposition auch wenn man mal
ganz genau hinhört aus den eigenen
Reihen und politisch wünschenswert dass
daraus auch mal Konsequenzen gezogen
werden Selbstreinigung ist da das
Stichwort denn wenn man so einen Fehler
macht so einen Debakel macht und dann
daraus keine politischen Konsequenzen
zieht ist das Ganze problematisch ohne
jede Frage aber so ist Politik eben auch
manchmal manchmal kleben Politiker auch
an ihren Ämtern wir sprechen noch mal am
Ende der Sendung Dominik da bist Du noch
mal bei uns ich soll mir bis dahin auch
ein paar User Fragen noch an Dich
deswegen danke für den Moment jetzt
haben wir nämlich die Möglichkeit hier
im Studio zu sprechen und dem ganzen an
juristische Einordnung zu geben das wird
Christoph Schneider von unserer
Redaktion Recht und Justiz für uns
machen schön dass du da bist Christoph
hallo
bevor wir beide sprechen schauen wir
auch noch zusammen in Ton rein denn es
gibt auch natürlich jetzt Resonanz auf
dieses Gutachten es gibt sowieso auch
Resonanz anderer Parteien über was da
also passiert ist und aber wir haben
auch noch ein Ton von Volker Wissing
einen zweiten Ton indem wir jetzt noch
mal gemeinsam reinhören wollen und da
ist auch was drin wo wir gleich
einstellen können zusammen mit Christoph
und der juristischen Einordnung
fachlich war es ein mehr als
markhaltiges Unterfangen einen solchen
Vertrag zu unterzeichnen wo man wusste
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch
ist dass diese Entscheidung auf
europäischer Ebene gegen die PKW-Maut in
Deutschland ausfallen wird
scheuer hatte also damals Verträge schon
unterschrieben als das EuGH Urteil noch
ausstand und jetzt sagte er eben Volker
Wissing wir haben es gehört in dem Ton
scheuer muss vorher gewusst haben dass
die Entscheidung gegen seine Maut
ausfällt und kann sowas also durch ein
guter achten überhaupt nachgewiesen
werden dass er das wirklich vorher
gewusst haben kann dass also das EuGH
Urteil negativ dann entscheidet ganz
schwierig zu sagen also zumal andreas
Scheuer sich auf den Standpunkt stellen
kann das ja der Generalanwalt beim
Europäischen Gerichtshof in seinem
Schlussantrag ja die PKW-Maut nicht
kippen wollte also das ist so wir sagen
bei uns in der rechtsredaktion immer der
Europäische Gerichtshof in vielen Fällen
oder in den allermeisten Fällen folgt
ihr den General Anwalt also der den
entschlussbewertung vornimmt und den
ganz vielen Fällen sagt der europäische
Gericht so viel übernehmen das und in
dem Fall hatte der Generalanwalt am
Europäischen Gerichtshof tatsächlich
gesagt er hält die PKW-Maut für Europa
rechtskonform und der Europäische
Gerichtshof hat aber dann
2019 anders geurteilt das kommt vor und
das ist aber sicherlich jetzt kein Grund
um da jetzt anders zu argumentieren es
gibt schon viele Kommentare und Fragen
im Stream da gucke ich direkt mal rein
und gerade eben für diese juristischen
Fragen weil du bist ja jetzt auch genau
dafür bei uns und zwar fragt sich hier
Thomas Trader bei Youtube direkt als
erstes mal was ist die Rechtsgrundlage
für eben den möglichen Schadenersatz den
man dann von scheuer fordern könnte was
wäre die Rechtsgrundlage also die
Rechtsgrundlage ist dass es ein
sogenannten
Amtshaftungsanspruch gibt das heißt ein
Beamter haftet normalerweise für Schäden
die ein Ausübung seines Amtes durch
Verletzung seiner amtpflicht ein dritten
vorsätzlich oder fahrlässig zugefügt hat
und nach unserem Grundgesetz geht die
Haftung auf den Staat über und der Staat
kann in Fällen von Vorsatz in grober
Fahrlässigkeit Regress nehmen beim
handelnden Amts Alter also bei Herrn
scheuer so weit so einfach und klar aber
diese Regressforderung Liebe auf einer
gesetzlichen Grundlage und in
Deutschland ist es so das ist bei
Bundesbeamten möglich also das
Bundesbeamtengesetz das es gibt da hat
der Gesetzgeber die Möglichkeit eines
Rückgriffs geschaffen dass man Regress
nehmen kann aber es gibt auch wir leben
in einem Land das in dem vieles sehr
sehr gut geregelt ist gibt es auch ein
bundesministergesetz und da findet sich
keine Parallele rückgriffsvorschrift und
deswegen wird ja auch nicht nur aufgrund
dieses Falls aber auch sonst diskutiert
muss man so eine Vorschrift schaffen
dass man so eine Vorschrift schaffen
könnte das wäre theoretisch möglich denn
in unserem Grundgesetz heißt es auch
dass bei Vorsatz und ober Fahrlässigkeit
ein Rückgriff vorbehalten bleibt
vorbehalten heißt aber dann ist bedarf
trotzdem der Ausformulierung in einem
Gesetz und im Bundesbeamtengesetz haben
wir das nicht im Minister gesetzt und
andreas Scheuer ist Minister gewesen
aber nicht Bundesbeamter der gehandelt
hat und insofern scheidet hier eine
Anspruchsgrundlage danach aus du hast im
Vorsatz grobe Fahrlässigkeit
angesprochen und ich hatte es in der
Sendung auch schon gesagt es gibt
Reaktionen auch andere Parteien Anton
Hofreiter von den Grünen zum Beispiel
hat sich geäußert und gerade auf diese
zwei Punkte oder auf einen Punkt das
weiß ich noch Bezug genommen wir hören
mal zusammen rein sprechen dann darüber
ich bin der Meinung dass andreas Scheuer
ein Teil seines privaten Vermögens dafür
bezahlen sollte das ganze ist
vorsätzlich passiert er hat das ganze
nur gemacht um den Vertrag noch vor der
Landtagswahl abzuschließen weil er
dachte mit der wie ersten Hand der
Ausländer Maut und keiner populistisch
Punkte für die CSU machen
also zwei spannende Punkte einmal
fordert Hofreiter eben er soll mit dem
Privatvermögen haften und einmal das
haben wir eben schon angesprochen sagt
er hätte vorsätzlich das vorsätzlich
getan Volker Wissing der aktuelle
Verkehrsminister der spricht von dem Maß
an Fahrlässigkeit was man da also jetzt
prüfen sollte wenn ihm jetzt das eine
oder das andere nachgewiesen würde du
hast es gerade ja auch schon gesagt wer
dann jetzt überhaupt was zu machen oder
eben nicht weil du sagst in diesem
Minister gesetzt da steht gar nichts
drinne selbst wenn grobe Fahrlässigkeit
oder eben Vorsatz dabei rauskommen
sollte genau also das Entscheidende ist
ich glaube übervorsatz müssen wir an der
Stelle nicht diskutieren so wie Anton
Hofreiter ist gesagt hat denn im
juristischen Sinne ist Vorsatz die
wissenschaftliche und willentliche
Tatbestandsverwirklichung also als hätte
andreas Scheuer von Anfang an vor gehabt
den deutschen Staat zu schädigen um
diese Maut betragen das wird sicherlich
jeder vernünftig denkende Mensch sagen
dass das so nicht der Fall gewesen ist
aber es stellt sich natürlich schon die
Frage der sogenannten groben
Fahrlässigkeit also ist da nicht etwas
im Spiel gewesen damit als er gesagt hat
ich unterschreibe diese Verträge noch
ehe der Europäische Gerichtshof
geurteilt hat den dominik schepker hat
das ja vorhin auch schon gesagt dass
es ja deutliche Warnsignale gab das
möglicherweise dieses Gesetz nicht
Europa rechtskonform ist und das
trotzdem andreas Scheuer diese Verträge
unterschrieben hat
da wäre zumindest die Möglichkeit einer
groben Fahrlässigkeit zu prüfen aber es
ist trotzdem die Frage ob anschließend
man tatsächlich ihm habhaft werden kann
tatsächlich weil wir diese allgemeine
Regelung so nicht haben also auch das
mit dem Privatvermögen steht er dann
also wirklich noch in den Sternen es
gibt noch viele weitere Kommentare ich
schaue hier noch mal rein also hier
schreibt zum Beispiel Waltraud
zimmerbauer per Mail ich finde das ein
Politiker der in seiner eigenen
Selbstherrlichkeit eine Unterschrift
leistet ohne einlaufendes Verfahren beim
MGH abzuwarten den Schaden zu tragen hat
also hier eine Meinung eher in Richtung
er sollte seine Strafe geben oder er
sollte zumindest haftbar gemacht werden
dagegen schreibt hier Maria Anna bei
Youtube so sehe ich die Maut und scheuer
dumm finde sagt sie persönlich für
politische Fehler zu haften finde ich
schwierig da ist Türen für andere Fälle
öffnen würde die Konsequenz sollte an
der Urne gezogen werden jetzt spricht
hier Maria Anna an das ist vielleicht
auch schwierig ist persönlich für
politische Fehler zu haften gibt es denn
irgendein Beispiel Christoph in der
Vergangenheit wo ist das überhaupt
jemals gehabt dass da ein Politiker
juristisch belangt wurde für die
Entscheidung im Amt ja ich hatte es
gegeben bei Kommunalpolitiker bei
Kommunalpolitiker also Oberbürgermeister
sind Beamte und können dann auch in
Verantwortung genommen werden also ein
Beispiel war die ehemalige Bonner
Oberbürgermeisterin Babel Diekmann die
wurde als kommunal Beamtin vor drei
Jahren vom Verwaltungsgericht Köln
verurteilt der Stadt Bonn eine Millionen
Euro Schadenersatz zu bezahlen am Ende
hat man sich auf eine Zahlung von
200.000 Euro geeinigt entscheidend hier
aber trotzdem eine
ex-oberbürgermeisterin musste persönlich
für ein finanzielles Desaster haften das
war passiert sie hat die Ansiedlung
eines Kongresszentrums betrieben hat er
für die Stadt Bonn
eine großzügige
aushaltung für die beteiligten
Unternehmen übernehmen lassen die Sache
gegen schief die Ausfälle mussten
bezahlt werden am Ende hat Bonn das
heutige World Conference Center Bonn in
eigener Trägerschaft gebaut und hat
anschließend Frau Diekmann als
Kommunalpolitikerin Anspruch genommen ja
das hat also schon gegeben und ein
anderes Beispiel eines verurteilten
Politikers ist da der ehemalige
rheinland-pfälzische Finanzminister
Ingolf Deubel Ingolf Deubel hat den
riskanten Ausbau des Nürburgrings der zu
einem Freizeit und Erlebnispark
vorangetrieben werden sollte der hat
diesen schnitzkanten Ausbau mit
gefördert und wurde in einem
Strafverfahren tatsächlich da war er
nicht mehr in Amt und Funktion unter
anderem auch wegen Untreue zu einer
Haftstrafe von zwei Jahren und drei
Monaten verurteilt also da gab es schon
ein Signal des Staates aber auch hier
die Unterscheidung er ist da nicht wegen
seiner Tätigkeit als Finanzminister in
Rheinland-Pfalz verurteilt worden
sondern weil er parallel noch
Aufsichtsratschef der eigenen
Nürburgring GmbH war und da hat man
gesagt als
Aufsichtsratschef hat man Treue
Verantwortung und da kann man auch wegen
untreuer belangt werden und Herr Deubel
hat tatsächlich bis zum vergangenen Jahr
im Gefängnis gesessen
es gibt noch mehr Fragen an dich hier im
Stream und zwar eine kommt von Sven
Odendahl bei Facebook er schreibt könnte
man eine Regel etablieren dass alle
Verträge über eine gewisse Höhe zuvor
durch den Bundesrechnungshof auf Risiken
Getrieb geprüft werden müssen siehst du
da irgendwelche chancenrechtlich also
das ist eine Frage wie auch jeweils
Ministerien organisiert sind sicher wäre
das eine mögliche Kontrollinstanz aber
das dann auch die Frage wo fängt man an
solche Verträge zu prüfen wo lässt man
es sein also dafür hat eigentlich jedes
Ministerium schon einen gut
ausgestatteten Beamtenapparat der
eigentlich über solche Dinge auch machen
soll und natürlich Fragen die sie
stellen da kann man sich auch als
Ministerium entsprechenden Expertenrat
holen also das ist durchaus möglich weiß
aber nicht ob das eben so konkret
umsetzbar ist weil man dann auch gewisse
Höhen Spielräume einfach definieren
müsste wo da möglicherweise eine
Einstandspflicht oder eine
Kontrollpflicht des Bundesrechnungshof
ein sitzt und der Punkt ist der
Bundesrechnungshof prüft ja Dinge
eigentlich auch selten im Voraus
meistens danach und dann erschrecken wir
immer alle wenn mitgeteilt wird der
Bundesrechnungshof hat wieder die und
die Mängel festgestellt die und die
Ausgaben die zu viel getroffen worden
sind ist eigentlich mehr eine
Kontrollinstanz und geht das jetzt
eigentlich wirklich nur um andreas
Scheuer oder geht es auch um sein ganzes
Ministerium damals um auch andere
Menschen mit denen er zusammengearbeitet
hat oder geht es jetzt wirklich in
dieser Sache nur um den Minister allein
also ich glaube dass dieses Gutachten
sicherlich auch dazu gedacht ist diese
Umstände dann auch noch mal aufzuklären
um vielleicht auch noch mal zu schauen
wer hat andreas Scheuer beraten also da
wird es sicher Leute in seinem Umfeld
gegeben haben die Einschätzungen gegeben
haben wie man sich dazu verhalten hat
also dass jemand ganz alleine so eine
weitreichende Entscheidung in so einem
großen Spielraum oder in so einem großen
Raum trifft halte ich persönlich für
mich sehr deutlich also ich glaube eher
jetzt da andere noch mit befasst waren
und das wird man sich einfach anschauen
und das ist vielleicht auch eine
Möglichkeit dieses Gutachtens einfach
mal aufzuzeigen was sind da für Schritte
gelaufen und natürlich werden wir wenn
dieses Gutachten vorliegt vielleicht
nicht gerade vor der bayerischen Wahl
oder auch vor der hessischen Wahl die
ansteht glaube ich fast am selben Tag
dann wird man natürlich schauen wenn
diese Ergebnisse eines Tages fest stehen
welche Konsequenzen sind daraus zu
ziehen und ich würde da gerne noch mal
auf diese eine Userin kommen die gesagt
hat das ist dann eben das zweischneidige
Schwert schafft man ein Gesetz ist die
Frage kann man Politiker dann noch in
bestimmte verantwortungsvolle Position
bringen weil ihn klar sein muss dass sie
irgendwann auch persönlich haften wer
trifft denn da noch
risikofreudige Entscheidungen gerade
wenn sich Wetterlagen politische
Wetterlage ändern gibt da auch wieder
Kommentare dazu also zum Beispiel
Florian regt ja ich hoffe es hat das
richtig ausgesprochen schreibt bei
Facebook das Gutachten kostet dann
wieder eine Million und das Ergebnis
steht heißt nein man kann ihn nicht
richtig Belangen so die Meinung hier von
Florian damit natürlich auch ein
bisschen ausführlichere Ausführungen
davon Christoph dazu gehört es gibt hier
aber auch von Clemens den Kommentar bei
Facebook er schreibt alle Politiker die
nachweislich Geld verschwendet haben
sollten ihre Pension aberkannt bekommen
und zusätzlich noch eine Strafzahlung
leisten müssen hier vielleicht auch noch
mal die spannende Frage dann endlich
zurückgespielt sowas wie eine Pension
aber erkannt bekommen den Posten
verlieren könnten das dann also auch
Konsequenzen sein wenn sowas dann
wirklich dieses Gutachten da irgendwas
nachweist
ich glaube für diesen aktuellen Fall
sicherlich nicht sondern diese
Konsequenzen müssen sich dann einfach
daraus ergeben wenn dieses Gutachten
feststeht und man dann weitere Schlüsse
ziehen kann das ist jetzt einfach zu
früh das zu sagen aber sicher wird man
über solche Möglichkeiten diskutieren
aber ich glaube Anton Hofreiter hat er
in demselben Interview gesagt wurde uns
den Ausschnitt vorgespielt hast meine
ich auch man will ihm eigentlich
erwähnen nicht die Pension aber
erkennbar er sagte er ist ja
ausdrücklich gewählter Mandatsträger er
ist ja für die CSU weiter im Bundestag
und im Prinzip wenn jemand andere
Meinungen hat das hat der ein Kollege
von der Süddeutschen Zeitung sehr
treffen geschrieben dann muss der Wähler
an der Wahl ohne entsprechend reagieren
dann also nur zum Schluss noch mal
wirklich so deine zusammenfassende
Einschätzung was können wir von so einem
Gutachten jetzt erwarten und was können
wir davon nicht erwarten also ich glaube
von dem Gutachten kann man erwarten dass
einfach noch mal die Umstände aufgeklärt
werden das vielleicht auch noch mal
zeitlich jetzt Zusammenhänge deutlich
werden
dann vielleicht verscheuert trotzdem
unter irgendeinem Druck von dem wir
nichts wissen denn ansonsten ist
natürlich die Überlegung 2018 in Vertrag
abzuschließen ist abzuschließen Verträge
abzuschließen mit zwei
Organisationen die die Maut betreiben
sollten schon etwas
eigenartig wenn auch ein Verfahren beim
Europäischen Gerichtshof anhängig ist
zumal ich glaube auch diese beiden
Unternehmen gesagt hatten dass sie gar
nicht so auf einer Eile bestehen sondern
durchaus auch eine spätere
Vertragsunterzeichnung auch möglich
gewesen wäre also ich glaube man muss
diese zeitlichen Umstände einfach noch
mal sehen dass das noch mal
aufgearbeitet wird was da
zusammengewirkt hat
und ob am Ende tatsächlich eine Haftung
steht ich will es mal so formulieren
auch immer noch vor Gericht und auf
hoher See sind wir in einer bestimmten
Hand ähm es gibt keine Entscheidung die
es nicht gibt aber ich würde nach meinem
Kenntnisstand aktuell eher davon
ausgehen dass wahrscheinlich
andere kressforderungen eher schwierig
wären Einschätzung von Christoph
Schneider von Recht und Justiz bei uns
in der Redaktion hier im Haus vielen
Dank und wir können jetzt noch mal
sprechen mit Dominik Chapka ich habe
auch noch ein bisschen in eure
Kommentare geschaut und gesammelt
dominik ist jetzt noch mal bei uns wir
hatten ja eben gerade auch schon gehört
in diesem Jahr wird nämlich gewählt in
zwei großen Bundesländern in Bayern und
in Hessen dazu vielleicht auch noch mal
auch die Meinung auf jeden Fall der CSU
sei hier gesagt die äußert sich
natürlich auch dazu also nach der
Meinung der CSU ist das Gutachten ein
Wahlkampfmanöver das wurde da schon klar
wir hatten vor rund zwei Wochen CSU-Chef
Söder hier im heute journal der sagte
zur Selbstkritik lediglich dass sei
jetzt ärgerlich dass er so ein hoher
Millionenbetrag im Raum steht will die
CSU da etwas kleiner reden oder wollen
eben die anderen Parteien mit auch den
den beiden Wahlen vor der Brust etwas
größer reden was da deine Einschätzung
Dominik ich würde sagen beides stimmt
natürlich versucht die CSU das Thema
runter zu spielen und zu sagen wir haben
das ja nicht alleine entschieden da war
der Bundestag mit dabei der
Bundespräsident hat das Gesetz
unterschrieben also die CSU versucht
diese Schuld auf verschiedene Schultern
abzuladen und die Opposition versucht
das Thema der CSU in die Schule zu
schieben und man merkt auch um das
nochmal ganz klar zu sagen niemand hier
in Berlin geht davon aus weil das
bundesministergesetz so ist wie es ist
Christoph hat es gesagt dass am Schluss
die CSU das Herr scheuer am Schluss
privat dafür haften wird müssen also das
erscheuer 243 Millionen Euro bezahlen
wird davon geht hier keiner aus auch
nicht von 200.000 €, weil die Gesetze so
sind wie sie sind und deswegen ist es
auch nicht ganz richtig wenn Volker
Wissing der Amts Nachfolger sagt das
Ganze sei eine juristische Frage die
jetzt zu klären sei und keine politische
natürlich ist dieses Gutachten zu
allererst politisch um noch mal ganz
klar die Schuldfrage in Richtung CSU zu
schieben zu dieser politischen Frage du
hast es gesagt gibt es jetzt hier auch
von Katrin Bartelt bei Facebook noch die
Frage ab wann ist denn ein Eingreifen
des gesamten Bundestags möglich oder
Pflicht wenn da also Ministerium ein
Minister solche Entscheidungen trifft
was würdest du sagen der Bundestag muss
die Gesetze letzten Endes verabschieden
also auch wenn ein Minister ein Gesetz
schreibt muss der Bundestag das ganze
verabschieden und der Bundespräsident
muss es am Schluss unterschreiben der
Bundestag kann jetzt theoretisch mit der
Mehrheit sagen wir finden dieses Gesetz
so doof wir machen das nicht und da hat
die CSU natürlich schon einen Punkt es
hat ja am Schluss nicht andreas Scheuer
im Alleingang dieses Gesetz unter Dach
und Fach gebracht ohne einen
Bundestagsbeschluss Klammer auf mit
Mehrheit der damaligen großen Koalition
mit Mehrheit der CSU der CDU und der SPD
ist das Ganze damals verabschiedet
worden was man schon sagen muss der
Bundespräsident prüft am Schluss nur ob
das Gesetz konform zustande gekommen ist
also der würde jetzt nicht den Inhalt
Prüfen von daher hatte auch der
Bundespräsident der nicht wirklich was
entscheidungsmäßig in der Hand also so
gesehen kann der Bundestag ein Gesetz
schon stoppen er hat aber nicht gemacht
und jemand mit dem Kürzel j.h Heinz
Beitrag dazu noch könnte man nicht
einfach eine vier-augenpflicht einführen
ab gewissen Grenzen also Minister und
Kanzler müssen unterschreiben in
Unternehmen sind solche
entscheidungsgrenzen ja üblich ja das
stimmt Klammer auf das muss man am
Schluss auch machen Gesetze werden im
Kabinett auch mit Einstimmigkeit
durchgewunken und das ist ja nicht so
dass die damalige Kanzlerin Angela
Merkel das ganze nicht auch politisch
unterstützt hätte sie hat zweimal gesagt
mit mir wird es keine Pkw-Maut geben
aber dann kam immer der Nachsatz die die
deutschen quasi zur Kasse bittet also
von daher das war schon die politische
Mehrheitsmeinung das hat die CSU schon
man könnte sagen so lange gequengelt bis
auch die anderen Koalitionspartner
zugestimmt haben das hat die CSU schon
auf normalen demokratischen Weg ähm
letzten Endes im trockene Tücher
gebracht das ist auch so gesehen alles
in Ordnung das Kind ist in den Brunnen
gefallen ich glaube ein vier Augen
Prinzip würde da so gesehen nicht noch
oben drauf helfen denn wenn die Chefin
wenn Frau Merkel ist nicht stoppt dann
kann letzten Endes die CSU mit den
Mehrheiten im Bundestag das ganze
natürlich verabschieden Dominik zum
Schluss noch die Frage du hast gesagt
wahrscheinlich dauert das eine Weile
aber jetzt noch mal ganz konkret wie
lange könnte dieses Gutachten dauern
gibt es irgendeinen Zeitplan irgendwas
von der Bundespressekonferenz heute was
für uns berichten kannst leider nein ich
kann auch nichts zu den Kosten sagen die
da gerade ein User angefragt hat sowohl
die Kosten sind noch nicht klar wollte
sich der Sprecher nicht so äußern auch
wie lange es dauert ich denke schon dass
das ganze noch ziemlich genau bis zur
Wahl bis zu den Wahlen im Herbst dauern
wird so politisch ist die ganze
Geschichte auf jeden Fall ich denke
schon dass wir dann auch noch meine
Diskussion kriegen werden ob man dieses
Gesetz nicht ändern möchte also ob man
künftig nicht Bundesminister haftbar
machen möchte wobei der gegenspricht so
ein bisschen wer will dann noch ins
politische Risiko gehen welcher Minister
würde dann tatsächlich 100 Milliarden
Euro Sondervermögen z.B verabschieden
das wird glaube ich eher die ganze
Diskussion werden das Ergebnis dieses
Gutachtens steht meiner Meinung nach im
Großen und Ganzen eher fest ich ich
glaube nicht niemand glaubt dass das
andreas Scheuer am Schluss wie sagen wir
Blechen wird müssen ich glaube nicht
dass scheuer persönlich blechen muss wir
werden uns alle widersprechen wenn das
Gutachten denn dann da ist bis dahin
erstmal vielen Dank Dominik Dominik
tschepker in Berlin danke dir für deine
Zeit heute gerne ich habe gesehen dass
in den Kommentaren eher mehr Kommentare
in die Richtung ich nenne es mal
probestrafe pro ja pro Verantwortung
ging ich möchte zwei noch mal zum
Schluss Vorlesen daniel thorsi schrieb
bei Facebook finde ist wichtig das auch
ein Minister seine Fehler erkennt und
fühlt somit würden alle Ministerinnen
vielleicht etwas gewissenhafte arbeiten
also quasi die Hoffnung dass dann davon
wenn es Konsequenzen gelbe ein Signal
auch ausgeht und die den Nord schreibt
bei Youtube trenne nie jemanden von den
Konsequenzen seiner Entscheidungen denn
sonst ist das verantwortungslos in
diesem Fall von scheuer wurde nicht
fahrlässig sondern trotz besseren
Wissens gehandelt so sagt der die Userin
und aber so ein bisschen aus der anderen
Bildung noch ein letztes kommentar von
Ricky Jäger bei Youtube als Politiker
genießt er eine gewisse Immunität und
kann nicht als Privatperson haftbar
gemacht werden dafür müsste er mutwillig
dafür müsste er es mutwillig gemacht
haben also mutwillig gehandelt haben
also unterschiedliche Meinungen im
Stream aber eben ein paar mehr in
Richtung es wäre schön wenn da also
jemand zur Verantwortung gezogen würde
für diesen Fehler wir werden das Ganze
für euch natürlich weiter im Blick
behalten wir haben es gehört es dauert
noch eine Weile also bis dahin müssen
wir uns noch gedulden für heute erstmal
danke und tschüss schönen Abend